[Musique]
je parle avec les animaux se comprend
salut petit rayon de soleil comme ça
j'ai envie qu'on fasse la copie d'un
sujet je vous donne 24 heures pour
parité chaque fois il se remet à parler
avec les animaux il ya chaque fois c'est
la catastrophe
il n'est pas question que je déménage
plus sûr plus mais toi ça bien dans
laquelle vais arrêter de parler aux
animaux sauvages bonsaï
j'aurais jamais cru que ce serait si
difficile de ne pas parler aux animaux
peut parler à longueur de journée si ça
fait du bien
vous allez passer trois jours avec elle
quand son parc qui les plus
extraordinaires des hauts fourneaux dans
un chien allez on y va encore grimper
[Musique]
elle ne me dis pas que c'est arrivé de
nouveau
tu es mon fils ap arabiya il ya des
animaux qui se font enlever nous allons
découvrir et ses voleurs d'animaux
alliant votre commande est prudent ce
qu'on peut appeler l'attention à vous
maison
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit elle se perd que
tu en poste parce que tu n'as pas
changer de chaussettes depuis quoi
depuis cinq jours elle dit ça fait trois
jours à tout casser
[Musique]